[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le matin du samedi 22 avril alger ces
veillées devant un spectacle imprévue
des unités de légionnaires et de
parachutistes occuper les points
stratégiques radio alger annonçait qu
l'armée s'est assuré le contrôle du
territoire algéro sahraouie
cette proclamation était signé du
général challe démissionnaire depuis
jolie une fièvre nouvelle s'empare est
aussitôt d'une population qui souffre
toujours de la plaie mal fermée de
l'algérie française
pendant ce temps les événements en cours
et on apprenait coup sur coup
l'arrestation du délégué général le
ralliement d'oran l'arrivée de salan le
discours du général de gaulle
[Musique]
si déjà dans l'édifice du complot
certaines fissures apparaissaient la
foule algéroise mon imaginaire rien
encore quand le lundi 24
elles envahissent et le forum pour
acclamer les quatre hommes qui s'étaient
emparés du pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
pour ben ali compte de la délégation
générale il nous apparaissait charles
salle un jour elle est tour à tour il
s'adressait à la population lui répéter
les mots qui activaient saffier mais
derrière les applaudissements de cette
foule pouvait-on ne pas entendre l'écho
des paroles qui avait prononcé la veille
le général de gaulle affirmant
l'autorité de l'état dénonçant l'action
des insurgés dictant des ordres pour
arrêter le drame
et
c'est un signe avant-coureur
annonçait-il déjà les clips ce rapide
des triomphateurs du jour l'embarquement
sur les mentions de 6 ans libérable
qu'on n'avait pas osé retenir pouvait
marquer que les hommes du contingent
regardait avec défiance l'opération est
resté fidèle aux commandes dans l'est
boxing à paris l'assemblée nationale
réuni en séance extraordinaire pour
écouter un message du président de la
république s'unissaient à sa résolution
de briser par tous les moyens
d'insurrection et approuver les mesures
prises pour le faire et soudain en
quelques heures tout s'effondrait
d'alger la majorité des unités
stationnées la marine l'aviation refuser
leurs contours au complot à l'aube du
mercredi 27
tout était rentré dans l'ordre les
gendarmes mobiles réoccuper la
délégation générale abandonné par les
quatre et généraux partout les troupes
fidèles avaient repris le contrôle
ayons forme quatre jours la conspiration
se diluait d'un seul coup devant le
refus à la fois de l'armée et de la
nation
[Musique]
derniera à la porte de la prison de la
santé un petit groupe en attend une
voiture qui entre sans ralentir le
général challe s'est constitué
prisonnier et ses comparses ont disparu
la parole est maintenant à la justice
l'épreuve est finie elle a été dure elle
laisse des traces douloureuses mais la
france a gagné
[Musique]
dans toute l'algérie la restauration de
l'autorité s'est opérée sans retard dans
la journée même de la reprise en main le
ministre d'état chargé des affaires
algériennes monsieur louis joxe
réinstalle est à la délégation générale
monsieur jean morin ramener en avion
ville ça là où il avait été déporté
[Musique]
alger parcours une patrouille surveillé
par l'armée offraient le spectacle d'une
ville comme assommés sortant d'une
aventure à laquelle elle n'avait peut
être jamais cru tout à fait dans son
immense immeuble garder militairement la
radio d'alger était redevenu france 5
et l'on voyait dans les commissariats
s'esquisser les premières remises
d'armes dont la récupération doit être
opéré sous réserve de perquisition
[Musique]
à
des terrasses on pouvait voir l'escadre
partie toulon mouillé au large
six bâtiments parmi lesquels le croiseur
colbert l'unité la plus moderne de la
flotte française et le porte avions à
ronan le colbert qui avait ramené à
toulon les cendres du maréchal lyautey
avait appareillé pour alger dans leur
même de l'accomplissement de sa mission
[Musique]
un dernier acte se joue est à zéralda
camp de repos où s'était replié le 1er
régiment étranger de parachutistes qui
avait été à la pointe de l'insurrection
le 1er rep demain n'existera plus de
zéralda bloqué par les unités du
contingent 60 camions ont emporté au
milieu des pétarades des fumigènes
l'unité rebelles jusqu'à sidi bel abbès
dépôt de la légion où elle sera dissoute
c'est maintenant leur triste où l'on
fait les comptes et où le destin
présente l'addition
ces hommes-là paieront leur folie ils le
savent ils acceptent ces commandes vient
de mourir
ce monde où un ordre devient une base de
discussion
il n'y a plus aujourd'hui dans l'armée
place que pour une morale est une
discipline
à bord du croiseur colbert la dépouille
du maréchal lyautey à regagner la france
19 coups de canon ont salué le retour du
grand soldat qui sut de 1912 à 1925
créer les bases du maroc moderne et
faire d'une région un perpétuel état de
troubles un état solide et un pays
moderne dans quelques temps la france
donnera à lyautey la glorieuse
sépultures des invalides
il attendra ce jour émouvant dans le
silence de la petite chapelle de saint
mandrier sous la garde des marins qui
ramenèrent cessantes
[Musique]
le standing international d'une nation
dépend de l'importance de sa production
de la capacité de ses usines et du degré
de modernisation de son équipement
on a vu d'ailleurs quel chemin dans ses
divers domaines a parcouru depuis cinq
ans l'industrie française les industries
de base comme les cimenteries qui ont vu
depuis la guerre croître
considérablement les demandes en
fonction des besoins de la construction
doivent poursuivre un effort continu
d'investissement les prés du crédit
national concourant à leur financement
ces prêts qui s'adresse aussi bien au
grand complexe sidérurgique cas des
firmes modeste se répartissent
aujourd'hui entre plus de 2600
entreprises pour un total de 341
milliards d'anciens francs
il s'étend aux affaires commerciales de
toute envergure depuis le petit magasin
d'alimentation jusqu'au supermarché il
n'est pas de secteurs de l'économie qui
n'en ait bénéficié
si bien que le crédit national apparaît
comme le ressort de l'économie française
et plata font les bonnes soirées d'un
cirque espagnol la virtuosité avec
laquelle ils font usage de leur force
leur a d'ailleurs valu de solides et
admiration la discipline musculaire de
ces deux athlètes au manu est telle que
les figures semble se suivre avec la
plus grande facilité
et pourtant
[Musique]
à notre époque de machines plus
étonnantes chaque jour il n'est pas
mauvais de se rappeler quelle admirable
mécanisme peut être aussi le corps
humain
[Musique]
brusque en dés et jaloux des lauriers de
grand-papa son grand-père était il est
vrai le célèbre matador de cordoue match
à quitte il n'est pas toujours facile
d'imiter son grand p
les jeunes la millière hausse qui
participe à cette course de taureaux
vont avoir l'occasion de s'en rendre
compte
lequel d'entre vous va se décider
messieurs ne vous pressez pas il y en
aura pour tout le monde
surtout pas de panique il faut la
dignité pour être un grand matador
[Musique]
oui mais un faux pas est si vite arrivé
le toro lui ne s'embarrasse pas de veine
fioritures
à ce train là on se demande s'il va
rester encore des combattants pour
terminer la corrida
et s'il n'en reste qu'un décidément le
courage ne paie pas on finira bien par
le 27 euros tout de même
[Musique]
non ce n'est plus une corrida c'était la
potiche
les femmes girafes vital de goualich les
a découvertes quelque part sur les hauts
plateaux de birmanie aux confins du laos
et de la chine
elles vont et viennent dans leur village
la tête posée au sommet d'une spirale de
métal leur coût peut atteindre jusqu'à
30 et 40 cm jadis ce collier vertigineux
servait dit-on à protéger de la mort sur
des digues
aujourd'hui il n'est plus que le signe
évident de l'élégance et de la richesse
l'une et l'autre se mesurant au nombre
des spires à partir d'un certain âge
l'abandon du collier équivaudra à un
arrêt de mort la distension des tissus
ne leur permettant plus de soutenir le
poids de la tête
ne croyez pas qu'une telle élégance vous
à l'oise yves t les femmes girafes
travail touchant avec peut-être
seulement à rien de retenue dans le
texte
[Musique]
à
armure ou carcan ou bijoux ou les trois
en même temps comme le monde est étrange
disait déjà marco polo
[Musique]